[Music]
the Democratic candidates for president
are on the road this week telling voters
that the United States is an awful
country America's institutions are built
on white supremacy squeaked beta or or
canned an event yesterday of all the
lies these people tell and there are
many this is the most absurd in fact the
United States is the kindest most
open-minded place on the planet the US
has done more for other people and
received less in return than any nation
in history by far Americans like to help
it makes us feel good some of our
deepest satisfaction as a country comes
from watching penniless immigrants
arrived on our shores buy into our
values and thrive we call it the
American Dream and nothing makes us
prouder it was in that spirit that in
1992 the United States welcomed
ten-year-old Ilhan Omar and her family
Omar was born in Somalia one of the
world's poorest countries who was then
ruled by a marxist military dictatorship
when Omar was six she and her parents
and their six siblings fled a worsening
civil war and wound up in a refugee camp
in Kenya they spent four years there
until America offered the family asylum
here and let them settle in Minneapolis
Omar's father drove a taxi at first then
got a job at the post office working for
the government
Omar meanwhile grew up free in the
world's richest country with all the
bounty that that implies she became a
citizen that went to work of the State
University a few years later she became
a member of Congress elected by voters
who were proud to see an immigrant
succeed
Omar is now at the age of only 36 one of
the most powerful women in America it's
an amazing story really only in this
country could it have happened
ilan Omar has an awful lot to be
grateful for but she isn't grateful not
at all after everything America has done
for Omar and for her family she hates
this country more than ever in a recent
piece in The Washington Post the
reporter put it this way quote in Omar's
version America isn't the big-hearted
country that saved her from a brutal war
and a bleak refugee camp it wasn't a
meritocracy that helped her attend
college or vaulted her into Congress
instead it was the country that had
failed to live up to its founding ideals
disappointed her and so many immigrants
refugees and minorities like her end
quote
if anything that's an understatement
Omar isn't disappointed in America
she's enraged by it virtually every
public statement she makes accuses
Americans of bigotry and racism this is
an immoral country she says she's
undisguised contempt for the United
States and for its people that should
worry you and not just because Omar is
now a sitting member of Congress johann
Omar is living proof that the way we
practice immigration has become
dangerous to this country a system
designed to strengthen America is
instead undermining it some of the very
people we try hardest to help have come
to hate us passionately maybe that's our
fault for asking too little of our
immigrants we aren't self-confident
enough to make them assimilate so they
never feel fully American or maybe the
problem is deeper than that
maybe we're importing people from places
whose values are simply antithetical to
ours who knows what the problem is but
there is a problem and whatever the
cause this cannot continue it's not
sustainable no country can import large
numbers of people who hate it and expect
to survive the Romans were the last to
try that with predictable results so be
grateful for Johan Omar annoying as she
is she's a living fire alarm a warning
to the rest of us we better change our
immigration system immediately or else